Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Subnautica
Now I'm still in experimental mode
I apparently have the worst luck in the entire world
and... uh...
I'm gonna start reading a (stammers like Mark does) name here.
Amanda Holly (shoutout) said: Mark, your game is glitched again!
The precursor base you went to is already finished
It's just glitched out
And I was getting tons of comments like that
APPARENTLY
The day the last episode came out...
And thank you ominous music for crumbling up (I dunno) just at this time, because I needed you emphasize my point!
(markimoo being quiet)
Just the day that I put out the new video is the day that Subnautica released an update
I went Into experimental mode because I was trying to find that cache
It was only available in the preview build, the not final build
BUT
there was some confusion because when I released the video was THE DAY that all of you guys could go see that stuff
So there was a lot of people that were saying "Your game is glitched" unfortunately no it's not glitched
and even less, fortunately, I've now put myself to the point where I can never go back to the original game
because I saved over in the experimental mode, I told myself I was going to get in trouble if I did that
and then I did that and I'm an idiot
SO
what Imma do now is just a few things and then I'm going to get right back into the lava zone
Because I told you guys that I was going to be there when I was opening up this episode
But
there is something else I have to do
Because EVERYONE absolutely EVERYONE in the entire world told me that I needed to
Scan the skeleton!
I FORGOT TO SCAN IT!
And somebody else said that the most terrifying thing about it is that apparently what we saw that the precursors
built a base around
was just the head
or not even the head it was just the mouth
and they had said it had an even bigger body below
But you know, I don't know if that's that terrifying
considering this head here is so unbelievably huge
which, I don't think I want to notice anything other than just that
so, I'm going to make my way there and also
I'm gonna say uh the first GiantGaming says
"That if turn off my interior lights, my exterior lights are going to work better
Honestly I can't tell a difference
So I'm going to assume that's good and assume that you're right and I'm going to make my way back to the skeleton
so I'll be right back
SHABOOP
Ahh there you are
Helloo
Hi.
So apparently you weren't the whole body
You're just the head
And you got a big head on you ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) because that must mean that your brain real big too
but I ain't scared of you (sure, mark...)
I think you're a big ol' lump of shit
and I'm gonna beat the crap out of you
Once I get my hands on you
Where's that crab squid?
Okay doesn't seem to be around
alright
whayagot ancient skeleton? huh? what're you up to?
Whoo-OO
what you got goin' oN
HUH?? WHOLE LOT OF NOTHIN'!!
(Adorable angry mark) HUH?? YOU THINK I'M SCARED OF YOU?!?!
THE ANSWER IS YES!
(calmer mark) but that's besides the point ok
got an ancient skeleton scan
that's good to know,
nice mouth
eeeee how many eyes does that thing have?
how many of those things are-
*MARKIGASP*
AAAH, THAT'S A CRAB SQUID!
alright gonna move on now
'scuse me I don't like being out of my
big safe boat
Cyclops: Welcome aboard captain (Cyclops: I have yet to call him daddy.)
Mark: Thank you! Alright Cyclops: All systems online
Mark: what do we got here
Alien lifeforms..
Fauna...
Deceased...
Okay here we are
Projections suggest this lifeform would have
been far larger than any other encountered on the planet
the remains date to seven thousand years ago
that's not that long ago
seven thousand years ago is a long time, don't get me wrong
but in the scope of
a species going extinct
long
and something evolving from that
no
that's not long.
That thing existed in this time era.
That thing existed... in THIS time era
That we are in right now!
It may 'a- that species may have gone extinct,
But that doesn't mean that things can't get THAT big...
right now!
In this game RIGHT NOW...
That means that things can get that big.
I'm gonna go see if I can go scan the other skeleton...
Uh, but before I do that I gotta 'nother comment from someone
who's name is literally just a bear face...
Like, literally, their face is just a bear...
And they said something that kinda relates to this...
Maybe the current Leviathins are just babies...
and later in the game they grow to be bigger.
I hadn't even considered the possibility
That a Reaper Leviathin
Wasn't fully grown.
(Ominous pause as Mark stares into the camera...BOO! Ha, got ya.)
I didn't even THINK OF THAT!
NOW I'm thinking of that!
Because what if that's the case?
I'm gonna try to scan this aih-I-I don't even know if this one's even gonna be scanable.
But I'm gonna try.
God dammit get out of my face...
I'm gonna try to scan it.
EEee-EEee! So big! (That's what she said)
TOO BIG! TOO BIG! Oh Kay, You're too big. (lol)
Ah, fuck, what was that?
No, you don't!
Don't come near me, OK!
So I can't scan that one, not that I wanted to.
But that is so weird considering that other skeleton was 7,000 years old.
It wouldn't be too far off to guess that that one is also of a similar age.
WHICH MEANS that these creatures here
Aren't completely gone!
And if you think about it more...
This is a whole planet...
We only landed in one, small, tiny section
Of the planet...
In the whole scope of the place that we've gone...
It's maybe, what, like... a few miles?
In diameter.
Maybe, if we're generous it's, like, 25 miles x 25 miles is the current scope of Subnautica.
And, what that means is...
There's at least 1,000 times more area in this entire planet...
For these terrifying creatures to exist.
And, as far as we know, this whole planet is covered in water
And there are probably oceans deeper than this.
If you go to the edge of the ocean here you will find a drop-off into the abyss...
That you will never come back from
What lurks down in those depths?
What creatures are waiting for you down there?
Creatures that can make your Cyclops look like a Tonka truck.
*BIG BOX BARRY THUD*
Sorry, 'scuse me, thank you for, once again, accentuating my point.
Hey, you wanna accentuate my point, too, buddy?
HAABlooski!
Ok...
Woah, hey, what the hell?
Wadiz that?
WOOAAH (Markimoo is intrigued)
What is that?
Ohhh...
Well, I mean, it's a skeleton, obviously...
But, if I'm not mistaken...
That kinda looks like a Sea Dragon!
Yah, that kinda looks like a Sea Dragon!
Immuna, immuna take out the other one, just cuz,
like,
It's a little bit, It's a little bit dangerous right now!
There's some creatures out there...
But, that looks like...
That is, 100%...
*World's Quietest Let's Play 4 confirmed* That's a Sea Dragon.....
Yeah, that's a Sea Dragon skeleton!
(Ominous moans in the dark. What'cha doing back there Barry?)
Yesh...
Where did you come from?
It is! I was right!
What the fuck?!
Well, that's bizarre!
Ookay
Well, got that!
See, and that just confirms what I was saying!
You can have...
SKELETONS!!!
That doesn't mean they don't exist!
Right now.
Ooh boy!
Thaz scary!
Ahh, okay, here we go!
OH!
Okay!!
(PDA) This semi-intact skeletal structure features a 99% overlap with that of a Sea Dragon Leviathin
(Mark) Suggestion... (PDA) Suggesting it is eezer the same species or a close cousin.
1. Head Trauma
(PDA) There is clear evidence of physical trauma to the head.
(PDA) The damage is so severe it must have been received shortly before death somewhere nearby likely caused by a high-speed collision with a solid object.
2. Age
(PDA) The skeleton has been well preserved. The calcium decay suggests that approximate death around 1,000 years ago.
(PDA) Bone growth suggests that the creature was is in egg-laying stage of it's life cycle.
Well, That means it's not a baby!
That's fer damn sure
But, ehm...
Still don't mean no happy things are going on there...
SO, I'm gonna make one more stop before I go down to the lava zone
And, don't worry, we're gonna see...
We're gonna SEE...
A Sea Dragon today (Oh nose)
We're gonna find one.
But I have to go in here because, apparently, this is, also a lot of people were very confused because...
In the new release (THUD) version that came out in the last episode
On the day the last episode aired.
Uh, this was all updated!
And in here, this is the disease rus- research facility.
This is where they were studying-... (Computer interrupts)
(Computer) This alien structure appears to have collapsed to the sea floor. Cause unknown. Computing theories...
Yah, I think I know the theory because I think you guys know the theory as well.
It was attacked by either a Sea Dragon, or something bigger.
To try to get, what I believe (Computer interrupts again)
(Computer) Detecting an alien broadcast. Linguistic analysis reads: "Caution: hazardous materials and lifeforms contained within.
Yah, YAH that's probably not good to go into, but here I go because I'm not know to be smart I'm know to be brave and stupid!
So imma do exactly those things that is that (Markiplier quotes 2017)
Ahright, c'mon, baby-boo!
Let's do this thaaang.
Ooh, laggy, laggy.
Shoobadiboop
Okay... now this is more like it!
Ooh, hello ion crystal!
Thank you!
Ahrighty then...
Oh, and a lot of people are asking me definitely to make ah ion...
Ion...
Thingamabobbers for my, uh...
My Cyclops to charge it with... (Computer interrupts)
(Computer) Interior walls in this section are substantially reinforced, indicating the designers were seeking either to keep something out,
(Computer) or contain it within. Whatever their intention, it clearly failed.
No joke, it did...
OH!
I need to make a purple artifact for this!
There's something in there.
OK, I'm gonna do that!
I might need more than one...
But, at least, there's plenty of, uh, ion things here,
I mean, I gotta whole bunch of 'em!
I've got...
I-I have enough to make whatever I want, um, and eventually I'll make the ion power cells.
But, right now, like, I'm not exactly herding for power, so...
But I think I'll be ok...
I don't need to dock it, I'm just gonna hop out right here.
Alright, so to make a purple artifact, I believe, it's pretty simple...
Yadda Yadda Yooptie
It is a fooptie booptie doo!
Ah, purple artifact...
Diamond times 2, do I have diamonds?
I dunno if I have diamonds on me here...
I DO! Ok, so imma at least gonna be able to make one.
eh...
alright, there we go!
Hello buddy!
Let's goo! We gotta see what's behind the walls!
Alright, waddu we got hee?
FLOOBITY BOOOO!
ShaaBOOWW
baby.
alright... open up! Open Sez Me!!!
Come on!
come on, there we go...
alright, alien research data, what do we got?
(Computer) Integrating new PDA data.
(Mark reading PDA) This device appears to hold alien research data. (Computer interrupts)
(Computer) Alien thermal plant added.
Wait, whaddid you just say?
Blueprint for alien thermal plant??
There's my thermal plant. OK, I'm not seeing it in here, what did it just talk about?
Is it something in the builder tool?
Hokay, I'm not seeing anything,
I dunno what it was talking about,
It might've been something I misheard, or something that's, t- I'm not in the game yet. (what?)
but, that's just bizarre.
So lemme read this...
(PDA) This device appears to hold alien research data. It seems that the alien civilization was facing a mass exctinction event, brought on by the bacteria.
(PDA) They established this facility to study the infection and possible cures in seclusion.
Of the specimens on record, only one survived infection with the bacterium. The closest translation of their symbol for this specimen is the "emperor."
(PDA) For some reason, this facility was insufficient to study the emperor specimen, and it was instead contained within a purpose-built habitat elsewhere on the planet.
(PDA) While it is unlikely that the specimen in question is still contained within the facility. It is possible the alien researchers left behind information relating to the cure they were seeking.
(PDA) References to the emperor containment facility in the data are scarce, but it's location is suggested to be with volcanic activity at depth approximately 1200 meters.
Which is exactly where we're going after this!
and exactly what we're gonna find very soon...
but MYYY intuition suggests that they were trying very hard to contain whatever it is they were trying to contain.
and it is very admiral whatever it was they were trying to do.
Oh, also
immuna... immuna watch my hands cuz apparently, uh, the hands do tell here!
and I know I'm infected, I definitely know that, but, um...
it ain't gonna be good for me.
So I don't know what this egg is to, but it doesn't look like any egg that I've seen before, so it might be to something very big
because the vast majority of the creatures on this planet are egg-laying.
What it said in the previous-
ok...
Take you...
What it said in a previous, uh, journal entry is that there was some sort of...
there was some sort of unified theory to all the species on here, and, uh,
it was... all the creatures are of a single gender, all aypled- able to lay eggs and all able to fertilize.
(PDA) Leviathin detected at facility perimeter closing at high speed. Exterior wall impacted with massive force.
(PDA) Lifeform containment unit 7 breached. General structure integrity compromised.
(PDA) Immediate specimen destruction protocol initiated. 314 specimens destroyed. 1 specimen unaccounted for.
(PDA) Evacuating staff on off-site sanctuaries. Planetary quarantine protocol initiated that the following sites ground-to-air quarantine enforcement platform power plant primary containment facility.
(PDA) WARNING: Infected individuals may not leave the planet.
So I know what happened.
Now I do.
I know exactly what happened.
The skeleton of the Sea Dragon we found outside died from blunt force trauma to it's head.
It got hit by something in it's head and then it died.
But that's just what the scans said,
What actually happened was it hit this base...
With it's head!
And dessstroyed it!
Somehow, it ended up totally catastrophically destroying this thing with...
Probably not just one hit
but it repeatedly bashed into this facility until it collapsed and fell.
And then the automated protocols destroyed almost every single living creature in this- (Computer Interrupts)
(Computer) Residual biological evidence suggests that indigenous lifeforms were brought to this location and subjected to intensive gene manipulation.
uhh...
(Creepy Ambient Sound)
OH, HEY!
Oh, that's creepy!
So it was trying desperately to free its eggs and one species on here was unnacounted for.
(Computer) Data pertaining to the bacterium is being downloaded. Caution: detecting atypical fluctuations in blood plasma proteins. A self scan is strongly advised.
Ok, gotta self-scan, I already did that!
Yup!
(Computer) Integrating new PDA data.
(Computer) Performing self sscan.
(Computer) Bacterial infection has spread to the skin and pulmonary system. It is imperative you find a way to neutralize the infection.
WOOAH
HOO KAY!
HOOO
ALRIGHT THEN
WHOOAAAH
OK!
HAAAALRIGHTY THEN!
OH, that's not good!
Whoakay, alright.
WELL!
Thaz new!
And not fuhn!
So imma 'bout to die!
Oh, my hands are green!
Oh, I am thoroughly infected now, okay, good!
So
This is all bad!
But, what's even weirder
Is that this warper...
What they said was that indigenous lifeforms were brought here for experimentation
So, the warper...
Is a modified version of the creatures that naturally live on this planet.
An' that's...
That's terrifying...
Like, these precursors, they were so caught up in their own, like...
Desire to experiment
Like, they were trying to find a cure for the disease that was wiping out their entire species
and, obviously, it did, everything, like, died.
This was a thousand years ago!!!
So, there was a quarantine protocol that happened a thousand year, g- years ago.
But, I'm thinking. That the Aurora crashing into the planet...
Like,
That caused...
It was contained...
Down here, at the bottom, and, I dunno.
Maybe the precursors all died from it, maybe they figured out a way... to, like, contain it.
I mean, to whatever success rate, that may not have worked, but, there can be no dispute:
A thousand years ago...
This all went down.
A thousand years ago they were researching a cure to the disease, and they didn't find it.
Was I infected the second I came down here, or was I infected only when I got down to this level.
Like... that's the question.
And, either way, I'm gonna die soon, and, suddenly everything in this entire planet is going to die.
If we don't do it.
Our damndest to make sure it survives.
(Big Box Barry) Welcome aboard, Captain.
Nigh!
I don't even know how that's gonna be possible!
How would that be possible?
Like, if, if they, they must have found some sort of a cure
Or else, I have no hope!
Thaz justa FACT!
That's just what it is!
There's no other way around it
other than THAT outcome
EITHER
There is a cure, and the ff- the precursors found a way to cure
Or immuna die.
(THUD)
And everything on this planet is gonna die, too.
Stakes pretty high! (THUD)
Stakes pretty high, but also I just remembered there's a PDA.
Aw, hey, buddy! I was just talkin' about you!
(PDA) Bacterial Mechanisms: Attatches on healthy living cells and mutates the basic genetic structure.
(PDA) Symptoms: Stage 1: None. Stage 2: Gradual immune system failure. Stage 3: Unpredictable alterations to biological structure.
(PDA) Stage 4: Complete shutdown of executive function. Confirmed deaths so far: 143 billion.
(PDA) Treatment procedure unknown.
WELL!
That's depressing!
143 BILLION creatures have died!
THANK YOU FOR ACCENTUATING MY POINT AGAIN!
So we gotta get down to that lava zone
There's no time to wait, we gotta go.
We're goin' immediately down there...
So I will see you back down...
In the depths...
Alright, so what I'mma do first, I'm down by Cyanite, I'm unna
Woops!
Nosed right into that one.
I'm unna go try to harvest that, because apparently it's working now.
In the most recent update...
And I want some of you!! (aww)
PLZ GIV ME I NEED U 2 UPGRADE JETPCK FOR THIS THING.
That work, I CAN'T SEE ANYTHING!
Ohp, there we go! Okay, that's what it is, ahright, goddit.
AHRIGHT!
Found one...
The other one must've fell down.
Ooh...
Why does it sound like you're crunchin'?
(Painful noise)
Why does it sound like you're crunchin'?!
Wait, NO NO NO NO NO!
You have an upgrade!!!
What the hell,
You, You have an upgrade!
I know you do!
YOU HAVE AN UPGRADE!!!
Why are you not working here?!
What the hell is happening?
But, it's not dying immediately, so I'm unna make this quick!
WHAT THE HELL JUST HAPPENED TO THAT?!?!
Do I need to pop it out and pop it back in again?
Because it doesn't seem to be working...
God damn it
GET OUT GET OUT GET OUT, C'MON!!!
God, dammit, oh, come back here, OH, it's fallin' fast.
OHH, this is scary,
OKAY
Got it!!
Gotta get back up!
jeezums
Why is that thing fallin' down, I'm gonna pop it out and bop it back in just in case it forgot that it had that...
Mmkai, put it back in!
There we go, JEEZUMS!
Don't do that to me!
Scarin' me like that!
Mister Fister, I may have talked shit about you, but I don't want you to die down here
You're alright Mister Fister.
I'm sorry I yelled at you. <3
I just... I just care about you... <3
Just want you to be safe...
Alright.
So I've got some Cyanite now...
I dunno how much I'm gonna need...
For wut I'm doin.
Cuz, I don't even have a modification station down here and I don't think I'm gonna be able to build one.
I may build a sea base down here at some point, like, I mea-
Aw, God dammit, get off my Goddamn boat!
I'll f- I'll deal with you as soon as I get clear of this and get away from... other SUCKERS of you...
g'ill, clear him off, Goddammit.
HOP OFF!
Ya FREELOADER!
NO, NO NO NO NO
Don't even (x1)
Don't even (x2)
Don't even (x3)
Get BACK!
BACK!
THE FRICK OFF!
Absorb that, you little SHIT! (Saltyplier)
At least down here I can make a lot of thermal generators.
And then I'd be able ta...
Solve my problems...
For power down here...
Alright, so, I'm now down in the lava zone again...
I didn't mean to be so touch and go about this, but...
(Dink) I'm back now
And I'm gonna find what I'm lookin' for, and if you guys don't know...
I'm not just looking for the Sea Dragon Leviathin, I am looking for him...
But I'm also looking for... the other alien research facility.
Not just the... other alien research facility, the primary alien research facility
So, you know, was is all chance...
And, I mean, convenient, obviously, for the gamesake, but also, very strained for chance.
Cause you know that gun?
That can't be the only gun.
One gun cannot stop, like, cannot defend an entire planet.
There has to be others all around it, on the other side of the planet, wherever you wanna put it, there has to be a lot more than just one...
But, this was luck...
We, the Aurora, was- were unlucky by being shot down and almost everyone dying (morbid, Mark...)
But number two:
It's not only just in a place where there was a gun, but a place where a primary alien research facility was.
At the heart of all of this...
The heart of everything that's happening down here all of this research, all the chaos of this bacterium.
(Spoopy sounds)
Wazthat?
Oh, hey...
And what is that?
What is that?
(Mark looks scared...)
Oh, I think I hear it...
Ho, no!
OH, NO!
Ok
I'm unna do su'm real stupid here!
I'mma 'bout to get outta my S- (Suddenly scared)
I'mma 'bout to get out of my Cyclops.
Oh, that sounds bad, because if I'm not mistaken, that is...
That is a standard Reaper Leviathin.
uy, uy, uy.
Ok, alright then!
I don wanna get outta my boat right now. I just wanna scan this-
Oh, it's HAWT!
Ooh, it's very HAWT
Alright, hang on.
Can I scan this?
No?
IT'S NOT EVEN SCANABLE?!
God dammit,
(Burly Accent) I'm burnin' alive here!
At least it's not that bad...
(Big Box Barry) Welcome aboard, Captain.
It's tolerable...
But what isn't tolerable is what I'm about to see in front of me...
Is it over here?
Oh...
It's gettin' more magma-E
WOOAAHH, HO HO HO! (Santaplier)
HOOOOO
HEEEEY
OH-HO!
HEY!
OK!
HI!
WOooah
Did'n expect ya to just be floatin' up there!
Howyadoin'?
Ya doin'
Ya good?
Ahh
WWHOOOOOOO
KAY, THEN!
Holy shit, was that a machine gun mouth?
Oh, fuck, dude.
Ahright, ya know what?
I'mma big, brave boi!
And have outta boutta just enough-
Uhm, save. (Yep)
I've had just about enough of you're bullshit here!
OhmaGod, you're beautiful!
mmm...
I'm here to square-off with you, buddy!
Oh, yeah, you think you can bash into an alien facility, er, your ancestor can?
HUH?
You think that's-
You think that's what's goin' on here?
You think I'mma ba- ah-
WUUHHHHH
UH-UH-UH
Don' look at me like that...
Ooh, hey, buddy...